the Supreme Court just made it legal for
every gay couple in America to get
married and marriage is a solid
financial option for everything from
employment benefits and estate taxes to
discounts on insurance but there are
some hidden costs to getting married to
consider these three things number one
income taxes for a couple where both
partners are well paid the marriage
penalty can be tens of thousands of
dollars here's an extreme example let's
say you and your partner each make 300
thousand dollars a year that means
you're each paying a top tax rate of 33%
but if you get married your combined six
hundred thousand dollars is taxed at a
top marginal rate of 39.6% that can cost
you more than twenty thousand dollars a
year
number two Roth IRAs for couples that
make over a hundred and ninety three
thousand dollars a year you might make
too much to be eligible to open Roth
IRAs the IRS prevents wealthier people
from taking advantage of the Roth IRA
tax break number three student loans
marriage can make it harder to qualify
for college or graduate school financial
aid for example the government's income
based repayment program limits your
student loan payments to a percentage of
your income if you make $40,000 a year
and have a hundred thousand dollars in
education debt your payment with IBR
could be two hundred and eighty dollars
a month but if you marry someone also
making forty thousand dollars your
payment can jump above seven hundred
dollars a month if your spouse makes
more than that you may stop qualifying
for the program
of course none of these hidden costs
outweigh the joy and benefits of
marrying a significant other love after
all has no price tag